on Valentine's night you posted a video
that with the sound of your next-door
neighbors having sex yeah and first of
all you are these neighbors that I mean
when you did that they must have found
out that you posted this video I don't
care
good cuz it way it made the rounds J go
edit almost every night and I'm sick of
it cuz I ain't getting none you know of
it and they're so loud and I even knew
my neighbor's name AJ and it's like why
didn't one day I was at my mailbox and I
heard her you know AJ are you gonna get
the milk or not and I was like AJ and I
turn around AJ so big I said wait a
minute
and the lady was like a little person so
when they're having sex I always think
he's killing her I don't know if he's
killing her or if it's sensational I
don't know but when I saw him and I saw
her I kind of understood okay yeah now
you know that you just called out AJ on
television you're gonna hear from AJ so
so keep it down yeah
a good way to get the word out there
you